nouvelle vidéo de cette chaîne la
sociaux tech aujourd'hui un portage à
mille ici qui nous parle des mouvements
de plaques tectoniques et en particulier
de la subduction avant toute chose le
générique gêné
[Musique]
et
on a bien sûr tu as vu des couteaux les
bons coups tombeur quel est le lien
entre la soupe et le cours de géo tiens
on va parler du mouvement de plaques
tectoniques est permis en fait par les
mouvements de convection qui s'effectue
à l'intérieur de la terre un mouvements
de convection c'est une répartition
match à l'heure au sein d'une matière
alors évidemment ici son attaque qui est
très chaude du moment défilent cette
source de chaleur va chauffer l'ensemble
du film est d'une certaine manière il va
y avoir une colonne de matières chaudes
qui va s'élever en au sens de qui va
après ses cartes et sur les côtés et
ainsi de suite
ça va recommencer pour bien les
bouillons qui arrivent et la matière qui
dispersaient sur les bords de la marne
si je prends un mets délicieux couteau
et je le mets au milieu on va voir
celui-ci va s'écarter vraiment sur les
côtés
[Musique]
et donc ça c'est vraiment le mouvement
de correction qui sont présents ici je
vous propose tout de suite une vidéo de
la bbc va vous montrer en images ces
mouvements de correction la coupe de la
terre réalisé ici permet de bien
comprendre le moteur à l'origine du
mouvement des plaques tectoniques le
noyau de la terre constitué
principalement de fer et de nickel en
fusion se refroidit par conduction c'est
surtout par convection gosses les
mouvements de convection entraîne le
magma du manteau jusqu'à la croûte
terrestre la croûte c'est d'écarteler à
l'endroit où les mouvements atteignent
la surface
ces cartes en la matière se refroidisse
et commence à redescendre faisant en
même temps plongé les roches remise
initialement mouvementiste l'échelle de
la planète les mouvements de convection
anime la croûte terrestre
en ce qui concerne la subduction on
pourrait dire que là où la plaque
s'enfonce les roche de la croûte qui
contiennent du carbone provenant
d'organismes morts sont enfuis vers le
centre de la terre en raison de la
chaleur présente dans les couches du
manteau les roches fonde en libérant du
dioxyde de carbone et d'autres gaz qui
retrouve l'atmosphère par une éruption
volcanique
le cycle est ainsi complet entre 8 super
saut super reportage que demander de
plus des rêves quand même quelques
petites choses à dire parce que la bbc
elle ne nous a pas tout dit sur ce coup
là la vidéo fait l'impasse sur un
élément important de la subduction à
l'endroit où la plaque s'enfonce elle
est en même temps raclée par la plaque
qui l'a chevaux la matière rocheuses s'y
accumulent et en même temps
l'enfoncement de la plaque créer un
creux que l'on appelle une fosse
océanique
vous avez des choses à dire commentaire
vous avez aimé la vidéo le pouce bleu
vous aimez la chaîne abonnez vous et je
vous dis à très bientôt atteint
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les voiles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]